hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing whether or not the
late great and highly revered Alber
Dumbledore ever created his own hwr
before his untimely death for those of
you who may be unfamiliar with the term
or haven't read up on your Harry Potter
law recently here's a quick review of HW
cruxes what exactly it takes to create
one and where they pop up in the Harry
Potter series to start with what is a
Haw rux and how is it made HW cruxes are
objects of dark magic that are created
by a witch or wizard who wishes to Live
Forever by immortalizing a piece of
their soul inside a vessel of their
choosing the witch or wizard must first
intentionally rip away a part of their
soul from their body by committing
Murder In Cold Blood now that last part
the bit about the murder being committed
in Cold Blood is particularly important
for our topic today but I'll explain
that in just a moment once the soul has
been split the witch or wizard then
magically places the piece of their torn
Soul into a vessel of their choosing in
order to immortalize themselves The
Vessel of a hawk rux can be just about
anything but it typically takes the form
of an inanimate object that said it can
be made by using a living being such as
an animal creature human or otherwise
making a living being into a hawk rux
however comes with substantially more
risk than using an inanimate object as
the vessel can obviously think for
itself and may not obey the creator of
the HRS whose bit of Soul lives inside
them for example think of Harry Potter
as Voldemort's hrug but again I'm
getting ahead of myself finally in order
to complete the process of making a hrug
the witch or wizard must perform a
ritual of dark magic that accompanies
placing one's torn Soul into the chosen
vessel what this ritual is exactly is
not widely known as the magic
surrounding this type of dark magic is
kept kept quite guarded by those who
believe it to be among the most evil
forms of magic in existence for this
reason it is not taught in the
curriculum at Hogwart School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry and many
students believe that not even the
restricted section of the school's
library contains any material on this
particular dark topic which brings us to
the series itself but before we dive in
any further a big thank you to today's
sponsor raycon raycon has carved a name
for itself in the premium audio Market
through its popular products like the
everyday earbuds and everyday headphones
and they truly have become musthaves for
any audio lover whether you're out for a
walk at the gym or just lounging around
the house rayon's products offer crisp
audio quality allowing you to enjoy your
favorite podcasts music playlists and
even YouTube videos with Optimum Clarity
personally I use them when I'm out
running at the gym or when I'm writing
scripts at the coffee shop as an ever
expanding brand rayon now reaches Beyond
audio with their raycon home and raycon
power Tech lines featuring products such
as the magic 180 power cable and foret
filter with their wide range of Premium
Tech products and tens of thousands of
five-star reviews finding the perfect
holiday gift for your loved ones should
be easier than ever so what's stopping
you from experiencing rayon's Great
Value and exceptional quality get an
early start on holiday sales by shopping
rayon's early Black Friday sale today
just go to buy rayon
/h Harry Potter Theory to get 20 to 50%
off sitewide it helps support the
channel and you get an awesome product
what have you got to lose thanks again
to rayon let's get back to the video
when do Haw Rees appear in Harry Potter
throughout Harry Potter we primarily see
hwr as used by Lord Voldemort in his
attempt to immortalize himself and live
forever in fact the dark lord is so
desperate to live forever and remain the
most powerful wizard in existence that
he goes so far as to to create seven HW
ruxers a feat previously unheard of the
fact that that many hres had never been
created by a single witch or wizard was
due to the idea that ripping one's soul
that many times would theoretically
cause incredible instability not only
for the soul itself but for the witch or
Wizard's remaining form which we see
with Voldemort's very non-human like
appearance not to mention the fact that
the dark lord would have had to commit
seven murders in Cold Blood and perform
the heinous ritual each every time a
ritual too dark to be written about or
taught at Hogwart School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry in any case the first hwrs
of Voldemort that we learn about is his
former diary from when he was a student
at Hogwarts the next three HW reers are
valuable possessions that belonged to
three of the four Hogwarts Founders
including Helga hufflepuff's golden cup
Rena ravenclaw's diem and Salazar sain's
locket Voldemort also managed to steal
his uncle marelo GA a loom ring later to
be discovered as the resurrection Stone
one of the three Deathly Hallows the
final hwr that the Dark Lord made
intentionally was his snake companion
the maledictus Nini with the seventh
truly final and inadvertent HW rugs
being Harry Potter himself this of
course brings us to today's theory in
question did Alber Dumbledore ever
create his own haul rugs let's take a
look Dumbledore's hawr the theory so
knowing that creating a hawk rug is a
bit of extremely dark magic that we've
previously only heard about Lord
Voldemort practicing and I suppose herpo
the foul how did a theory surrounding
the incredibly well respected Alba
Dumbledore and HW cruxes even come to be
well apparently the theory which has
been around for years is the result of
multiple fan theories the two most
prominent both claim that it's possible
that Dumbledore could have created his
own Haw Crux in his youth however they
differ in terms of which vessel they
believe he used to deposit his soul into
one of the very first theories claim CLA
that Dumbledore could have created a HW
Crux out of the Elder W another one of
the three Deathly Hallows while the
other more prominent Theory said that
his Haw crugs may actually have been
Forks Dumbledore's pet Phoenix these
theories were further supported by fans
unified belief that dumbledor has a for
want of a better word darker side this
clearly stems from the fact that he had
an intense friendship with G grindlewald
and held incredibly misguided
ideological beliefs in his youth not to
mention the whole he raised up Harry
like a for Slaughter thing and while
I'll admit the Dumbledore is not all
butterflies and sureb but lemons I
really can't believe that Alber
Dumbledore was capable of such a thing
Dumbledore's Hawk rux debunked in my
opinion the theory that Dumbledore
secretly made a Haw rux just doesn't
make any sense for one thing he's never
murdered anyone in Cold Blood while I
guess it's possible that he secretly
killed another witch or wizard this way
it seems rather unlikely considering all
the things that he eventually stood for
and opposed such as grinder wal in
Voldemort meaning the only instance that
we know of in which Albus was involved
in someone's death was his sister Ariana
dumbledor Ariana's accidental death
occurred around the year 1900 soon after
alus had graduated from his final year
at Hogwarts the issue here is that no
one not even Dumbledore himself knew who
dealt the magical blow that killed
Ariana in fact she may have actually
killed herself as she was an obscurial
whose magic was incredibly unpredictable
and dangerous even so if was responsible
for casting the magic that killed Ariana
it certainly wasn't done in Cold Blood
In fact Ariana's death was an accident
that he lamented until he himself died
feeling incredible guilt and remorse for
not better protecting his aien youngest
sister not to mention the fact that he
never performed the Dark Magic Ritual
associated with creating a hwr
personally I don't care how devastated
he was about the death of his sister
there's no way his feelings of remorse
and guilt could have clouded his
judgment to the point that he would have
m mutilated or disrespected her body to
create a h Crux then there's the
question of the actual object suspected
of being alus Dumbledore's horcruxes the
Elder Wand and forks the Phoenix at this
point in his life during the height of
his relationship with grindal and his
belief that the two of them needed to
reunite the three Deathly Hallows and
overtake the Muggle race there's no way
he even had the Elder Wand at this time
Dumbledore also had yet to meet Foggs as
it's widely believed that the first time
he encountered the bird was in the late
1920s when a Phoenix presumed to be
Forks came to the aid of credence who
was actually albus's nephew Oria
Dumbledore it's speculated that Forks
then became Dumbledore's companion after
these events there's also the fact that
fork Behavior towards Dumbledore while
certainly similar to the Loyalty of say
Nini to Voldemort or hwr to wizard if
you will is completely different in a
many number of ways to start with the
Dumbledore family and Phoenix's have a
long-standing history and relationship
in which the rare and Powerful Birds are
known to come to the aid of any
Dumbledore in need alus mentions that
his grandfather benefited from such a
bond and we also see this occur when the
Phoenix comes to Credence asde in
fantastic Beast 2 and then again in
three there's also the fact that after
Alber Dumbledore's death Forks sings his
lament and then leaves never to be seen
again if he had part of Dumbledore
inside him you'd think he would have
stuck around to help Harry defeat
Voldemort right my final note on why
this theory is not valid is the sheer
fact that it's been rejected by JK
Rowling who came right out and called it
strangely unsettling and with that we've
come to the end of another video what
did you think do you agree with me or do
you think it's entirely possible that
Alba Dumbledore did in fact have it in
him to create his own HW crugs and
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out the content on Spotify
as well as extra content my second
Channel Harry Potter Theory extra until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to
live